ن مشاهدينا الى هذه الصور من غلاف غزه حيث
يظهر تجدد القصف الاسرائيلي على هذه
المناطق المحاذيه نشاهد تصاعد اعمده
الدخان اذا بكثافه في منطقه باتت شبه
مسواه الارض مع كثافه القصف الجوي يضا
المدفعي من قبل جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على هذه المناطق المحاذيه لغلاف
غزه لازلنا نرى اذا تصاعد اعمده الدخان في
عده مواقع لازالت سياسه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هي استمرار هذا القصف على شمال
قطاع غزه وبنمط الاحزمه الناريه وبكثافة
هذا القصف المستمر مشاهدين ياتي بالرغم من
سحب القوات الاسرائيليه لعملياتها البريه
في عده مناطق في شمال قطاع غزه الا ان
استمرار
الغارات هو امر كما قال المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي لن ينتهي في هذه
المرحله معنا الان من غلاف غزه مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام ليحدد لنا المناطق
المستهدفه بهذه الغارات التي
نشاهدها نعم نحن ا امام معركه كبيره في
الدقائق الاخيره تدور رحاها في مخيم
البريج في وسط قطاع غزه تشاهدون هذه سحب
الدخان الاسود المتصاعده من اكثر من مكان
في المخيم ربما تسمعون
ايضا
تس تسمعين حجم الانفجار
في داخل المخيم نفسه نحن نتحدث عن
انفجارات هائله تسمع في الدقائق الاخيره
واضح بان هنالك معركه على الارض وفي
الميدان تجري ما بين القوات الاسرائيليه
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه نشاهد ان سحب الدخان
المتصاعده هي اكثر من موقع وفي اكثر من
مكان وقد تكون استهدافات ايضا لدبابات
اسرائيليه او لاليات عسكريه اسرائيليه او
لناقلات جند لان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
ايضا يستهدف هذه المناطق بالقنابل
الدخانيه اي قبل لحظات في محاوله كما يبدو
للتغطيه على القوات الاسرائيليه لانسحابها
او لتحركها او ربما لتوغل في اكثر من
منطقه هناك لكن واضح بان حجم الانفجارات
في مخيم البريج في هذه الدقائق اي تشي
حقيقه بان هنالك معركه كبيره اي قد تكون
حقيقه بدون مبالغه غير مسبوقه مقارنه مع
الاسابيع ال الماضيه رغم ان مخيم البريج
والنصيرات ومخيمات الوسطى شهدت حقيقه
معارك كبيره لكن ما نشهده الان تحديدا في
مخيم البريج لم يسبق ان شاهدناه على الاقل
في الاسابيع والايام الماضيه ونحن كنا في
هذا الموقع اكثر من مره على مدى الاسابيع
الماضيه حجم الانفجارات في البريج هو هائل
جدا كانت هنالك ايضا غارتان جويتان عنيان
استهدفتا وسط المخيم قبل اقل من نصف ساعه
وعقب ذلك كان هذا الدخان الكثيف الذي
يتصاعد من اكثر من موقع في داخل المخيم
نشاهد ايضا الى جانب ذلك او نسمع الى جانب
ذلك اي اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله
في اكثر من مكان في داخل ال
المخيم ربما تسمعون هذا امر حقيقه غير
مسبوق في ال الاسابيع الماضيه واضح بان ما
يجري هنا ليس فقط قصفا مدفعيا من جانب
القوات الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه يبدو ان
القوات الاسرائيليه تستخدم ايضا الصواريخ
المحموله في استهدافات في الداخل هذا ما
نستطيع ربما تقديره من حجم الانفجارات
وتقديره ربما ايضا من استخدام المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ايضا للصواريخ المحموله ولصوص
المضاده للدروع التي يبدو ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحاول من خلالها استهداف
القوات الاسرائيليه الراج والمؤ في داخل
مخيم البريج لكن الواضح من الصوره ومما
نشاهده ونسمعه الان في مخيم البريج اننا
امام معركه قويه وحقيقيه وب وكبيره
ومواجهه لم نشهدها في الاسابيع ال الماضيه
حجم سحب الدخان المتصاعده في المخيم تشي
بان القتال على اشده وان القتال شرس وبان
القتال يجري من مسافه قريبه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يحاول بين الحين والاخر من
خلال
المدفعيه المتمركزه في منطقه غلاف غزه ان
يوفر غطاء ناريا للقوات الاسرائيليه في
مخيم البريج بالاضافه الى القنابل
الدخانيه التي يحاول من خلالها التغطيه
على القوات الاسرائيليه او الاشاره الى
موقعها ربما من اجل تنفيذ عمليات اجلاء
وانقاذ لجرحى مفترضين ربما في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اطار هذه العمليه في نفس
الوقت نحن نسمع
الطائرات الزنانه الطائرات المسيره التي
تحوم في اجواء المنطقه بعضها بطبيعه الحال
طائرات استطلاعيه للرصد والمراقبه ونقل
المعلومات الى غرف العمليات المتقدمه التي
تدير ربما هذه المعركه وبعضها ايضا يحمل
الصواريخ والذي بامكانه ايضا ان يطلق
الصواريخ باتجاه مواقع بعينها في داخل
المخيم قبل قليل ايضا كانت القوات
الاسرائيليه قد استهدف فت منطقه جحر الديك
غير واضح فيما اذا كانت هذه غاره جويه لكن
انفجار كبير هز المنطقه الشماليه لجحر
الديك هذه المنطقه الواقعه بين الضواحي
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وجحر الديك هذه
المنطقه ايضا تتعرض لقصف شديد من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ولغات جويه من جانب الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي منذ ايام على اعتبار ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول كما يبدو توفير
غطاء ناري لقوات هناك ولكن ايضا قطع
الطريق على الفلسطينيين الذين ربما
يحاولون العوده الى المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه لان ما يستهدف في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا بين الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه
وجحر الديك هو الشارع المعروف برقم 10
الشارع العرضي الذي يقطع شمال قطاع غزه عن
وسطها وجنوبها ويمتد من السياج الامني من
هنا من عندنا في غلاف غزه حتى
ايه البحر وواضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يكثف من ضرباته الناريه على هذا المحور
للحؤول دون تمكن الفلسطينيين من عبوره او
اجتيازه للوصول والعوده الى منازلهم او ما
تبقى منها في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
لكن واضح بان الحدث الابرز والاقوى في
الدقائق الاخيره يبقى مخيم البريج المشتعل
في هذا القتال العنيف والشرس والذي يؤكد
على ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره
على المقاومه ما زالت قادره على التصدي
وما زالت قادره على تاخير تقدم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ومنعه من احراز اي صوره انتصار
في هذا الموقع ولا في مواقعه اخرى وهذا ما
يحذر منه كثير من المراقبين العسكريين
والمسؤولين العسكريين في اسرائيل واخرهم
يسحاق بريك هذا الجنرال المتقاعد الذي
اهميته تكمن وفي تحليلاته ومواقفه تكمن في
انه كان اول الجنرالات الاسرائيليين الذي
توقع هجوم السابع من اكتوبر بحذافيره كما
حصل تماما لذلك تؤخذ اقواله على محمل الجد
في اخر تصريح له يقول بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يبدو وانه يراوح مكانه دون
احداث اي صوره انتصار وان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يخطئ خطا فادحا في سعيه لحسم
هذه المعركه التي يبدو انها انه لم يعد
قادرا على حسمها والانتصار فيها عسكريا بل
انه يعرض جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي للقتل
والجرح في هذه المعارك لذلك هو يقترح في
في حديث هذا الصباح مع القناه الث ع
الاسرائيليه على ان يعيد الجيش الاسرائيلي
انتشاره تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس وفي
المناطق الجنوبيه لانه اصبح عاجزا عن
تحقيق صوره انتصار وربما ال الجنوح نحو
مفاوضات للافراج وربما الوصول الى صفقه
جديده لتبادل الاسرى مع حركه حماس اذا هذا
هو الموقف برمته وواضح بان هنالك استياء ك
كبير على المستويين السياسي والعسكري في
اسرائيل تحديدا من خبراء عسكريين ومن
قيادات امنيه واستخبارات سابقه من ان
اسرائيل لم تنجز شيئا بعد مرور 100 يوم
ويوم على هذه الحرب اذا مره اخرى كما تشير
الياس وترصد في هذه اللحظات هذا الدخان
المتصاعد بكثافه هو من مخيم البريج الذي
يبدو ان معارك ضاريه تدور فيه في هذه
اللحظات بالنظر ايضا لما سمعناه على
الهواء مباشره من اصوات انفجارات ضخمه
ونحن نتحدث عن مخيم البريج الذي يقع في
وسط قطاع غزه بالتالي هذه المعركه الشديده
التي قلت انها في في مشهدها الان تعتبر
غير مسبوقه في قياسا بالايام الماضيه هو
اذا يؤشر على حجم ما يدور من معارك هذا
انفجار جديد الان نراه في افق الصوره اذا
في هذه
المنطقه المطله على غلاف غزه وتحديدا مخيم
البريج وكما ذكرت هناك عمليات اخرى بطبيعه
الحال تدور في بقيه مناطق القطاع خاصه في
جنوب قطاع غزه اشكرك حتى اللحظه مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام لان